um while republican senator ted cruz
was flying back and forth from cancun
mexico late two weeks ago
democratic new york congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez
was raising millions of dollars for ted
cruz's texas constituents and was
volunteering
at the houston food bank for ted cruz's
constituents
now did ted cruz thank aoc
no he didn't did texas governor greg
abbott thank aoc
and beto o'rourke and all the other
democrats who fundraised for texans
they didn't did they thank aoc and other
democrats
who flew to texas and went to work at
the houston food bank
to help ted cruz's constituents no they
didn't thank them for that either either
and when ted cruz finally mentioned aoc
it was friday during his cpac speech we
saw this clip earlier during our ted
cruz clip
here it is again here is ted cruz making
fun of aoc
for her experience during the january
6th trump riots
bernie is wearing mittens
and aoc is telling us she was murdered
and the media desperately desperately
desperately wants to see
a republican civil war now what is ted
cruz
even talking about aside from just being
a disgusting human being
ted cruz is referring to the twitter
exchange
in which aoc had tweeted that quote
there must
or not quote she tweeted that there must
be an investigation of robin hood
for their role in the gamestop fiasco
and ted cruz retweeted aoc saying
fully agree and aoc instead of
sort of accepting ted cruz's i guess
bipartisanship
aoc tweeted a rebuke of ted cruz
saying quote i'm happy to work with
republicans on this issue
where there is common ground but you
almost had me murdered three weeks ago
so you can sit this one out happy to
work with
almost any other republicans that aren't
trying to get me killed
in the meantime if you want to help you
can resign
now some people loved this response from
aoc saying it's aoc standing by her
principles regardless
of whether on this one issue ted cruz
agrees with her others
were sort of upset that aoc responded
aggressively to a senator saying
i want to do i agree with you on this
particular issue
now ted cruz is so disgusting that i do
tend to side with aoc on this particular
one
but this is less about aoc and more
about
the fact that even republicans
from texas who did nothing for their
constituents during the storm
can't simply thank aoc for what she did
do for texas
aoc has done more for texans than their
own senator
dozens of people died in texas aoc
helped them
raised money went to texas went to a
houston food bank and worked
ted cruz went to cancun and he's making
fun of aoc
the the you know everybody lighten up
is the type of thing people say when
they failed to deal with something
serious
and they want everybody else to take it
less seriously
that's how they tell everyone not to
worry about it now maybe
people like ted cruz caoc as a sucker
for helping texans what i mean is
she didn't have to do it like legally
speaking
texans aren't her constituents she's the
sucker
maybe that's the view ted cruz has aoc
was
suckered into helping people who don't
even get to vote for her one way or the
other
either way these are really pathetic
people
and we can only hope that they are
eventually held accountable and like
i said last week unfortunately with ted
cruz's next election if he chooses to
run for re-election
still four years away i'm not super
optimistic that this entire fiasco is
really going to hit him in any way that
it will actually hurt i hope to be wrong
uh but i mean you know when a democratic
new york congresswoman is doing more for
texas constituents than their own
senator who's
trying to escape to the beach in mexico
you know that one of two things is going
on
number one either voters really don't
care what their elected officials do
and they care only about what they say
which is quite probable
uh or two there may not uh
we we may just not have a system that
has consequences
for bad actors in the political system
in which case we have to figure out
other ways to win these elections
probably some combination of the two one
of our sponsors is vincero
watches giving you 15 off a high quality
wristwatch
is the perfect way to elevate your style
own at least one watch that makes you
feel great when you put it on you can
often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy and
five-year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store and free shipping
at davidpakman.com watch use the coupon
code
pacman